Oh,
diversity is actually necessary because people differ in intelligence and the
different temperament and the different skills and so you actually need
diversity cause otherwise you can't take advantage of all those differences.
So you need diversity but you need genuine diversity and like what would genuine
diversity mean?
If you're trying to put together a work team,
you want enough,
you want people of sufficient diversity so that they more or less so that you
gathered together the appropriate talents to produce the implement that's
necessary to work properly in the world.
That's a competence marker cause otherwise your business is going to fail.
And so the proper diversity with regards to employment is that diversity that
meets the requirements of the business essentially.
Obviously that's why you try to hire people carefully and not randomly,
let's say
third error,
first errors.
There's
only a finite number of valid interpretations.
Second error is that um,
there aren't real differences between groups of people,
but there's more difference within the groups then between them.
Third differences,
social status and payment,
especially in a free democratic capitalist society is based more on competence
than on
power.
In fact,
we would say that when a person in a hierarchy starts to act like their position
entitles them to power,
then that hierarchy has become corrupt.
Harvey Weinstein is a good example of that.
I'm serious.
It's like he acts acted like a tyrant.
What happened to him?
It's not good.
Not good for him.
What he did was not good,
but it's an indication it's revealed.
It's an indication that that misuse,
so he's competent,
fine.
He gets to have position because we need people who are competent,
but that doesn't mean you get to turn into a tyrant.
If you turn into a tyrant,
then that overshadows your competence and you go.
That's the definition of a functioning state and our state essentially
functions.
It's not perfect,
that's for sure,
but compared to what?
It's the issue compared to your hypothetical Marxist Utopia.
Well,
compared to your hypothetical Marxist Utopia,
I mean we're living in Auschwitz,
but your what?
Your actual Marxist utopia is indistinguishable from Auschwitz,
so we're not listening to that comparison.
We're going to take a look at what we have and we're going to compare it to
other places that actually existed in time and geographically and by those
criteria.
It's like,
is there another,
you'd rather live,
do another place.
You'd rather live,
I mean a real place in a real time,
and you want to live back in 1895 even in the western world where the average
person lived on less than a dollar a day.
In today's money,
you want to live like those coal miners.
It's like the answer to that's no.
If you have any sense,
you should have some gratitude.
That's another problem with the postmodern neo Marxists like zero,
zero,
zero gratitude.
It's all,
oh my God,
I'm more pressed.
Of course you're oppressed,
but you're not oppressed by the Patriarchy for God's sake.
Yeah,
so you have status in a hierarchy.
You might say,
well,
that's like a reward to your s you're a high status person.
It's a reward.
The reward should be shared equally.
It's like a badge of merit that you get.
It's a privilege.
It's not the reason that in a capitalist society,
filthy selfish capitalists put you in a position so they can extract maximum
productivity from you.
And that's exactly why you're there.
You get paid,
you get paid.
So you keep working.
Why do we want you to work?
Because your work is actually valuable to us and so we're going to pay you so
you don't quit.
It's not a reward because you're a good guy.
It's not a privilege.
That's not what it is.
You don't hand those things out like merit badges.
That's not how it works.
This society is set up on selfish principles.
We paid people who are competence so they won't stop striving cause we want what
they can produce.
So you don't just distribute that like,
like it's a gift.
It's not a gift.
It's not a gift at all.
So that's another place where they're wrong.
Social Status and payment is the consequence of the selfish desire of
individuals and the group to extract resources of intellect,
creativity,
and industriousness from those who possess them in excess.
Now of course,
it's not 100% like that.
There's the incompetent people who rise to the top.
You can fool people and you can manipulate them and you can act like a tyrant.
And you know,
we might say maybe the system is like 30% warp to something like that.
It's not much more than that because we can account for people's success across
life by looking at their individual differences,
intelligence,
comp,
conscientiousness,
emotional stability,
creativity.
We can do a pretty good job of predicting their trajectory.
So there's error,
some of its health,
right?
Because sometimes you've got what you need,
but you get cut off at the knees or your family members do or you know,
some tragic thing befalls you the,
there's a randomness in the system that accounts for a fair bit of it.
And then there's a certain amount of corruption.
Fair enough.
But not so much that the lights go off.